[Music]  is Bella Hadid living a double life I'm  just really happy well not exactly but  Bella does have a blonde alter ego who  has her own Instagram account I mean  it's so crazy meet Rebecca the 21 year  old model introduced the world to her  new personality with this pic caption  Rebecca Harajuku at your service  Rebecca's ID account basically documents  Bella's Adventures in Tokyo Japan  rocking a platinum wigs from street  style fashion moments to dinner dates  with her gal pals blonde Bella appears  to be living her best life  it's so awesome you might think it's  attached strange but Bella's alter-ego  already has over 20,000 followers and  Counting  so Rebecca must be doing something right  and as the saying goes blondes have more  fun  [Music]  [Applause]